CHRISTOPHER SANSON:
Hey, everyone.
Welcome to Dev 301,
production-grade
build security for
developer workflows.
My name is Christopher Sanson.
I'm a Product Manager at Google
working on developer tooling.
And with me is Anthony Bushong,
Specialist Customer Engineer
who will be joining us a little
bit later to give a demo about
some of the new
features and concepts
we'll be talking about.
The increase in cyber
and ransomware attacks
over the last year,
including high profile cases
such as SolarWinds, has been a
wake up call for the industry.
Security is top of mind for
companies large and small
across all verticals.
In May, the White House
issued an executive order
on improving the nation's
cybersecurity in face
of increasingly sophisticated
and persistent threats
to the public and
private sectors.
In this 20 minute
talk, we're going
to introduce some
specific actions
that you can take to
create a more secure
build environment
on Google Cloud.
Over the last 20
years, Google has
built some of the most
secure computing systems
in the world, pioneering
concepts such as zero trust.
As part of GCP, we're bringing
these internal best practices
to our cloud customers
through both open standards
and integration in a variety
of ways into GCP's managed
services.
In June of this year, we
launched Open Source Insights,
an exploratory
visualization site
for viewing the dependencies
of open source projects.
And in July, we
announced SLSA, S-L-S-A,
an open framework based on
internal Google best practices
for formalizing the criteria
around software supply chain
integrity to help the industry
and open source ecosystem
secure the software
development lifecycle.
CI/CD is one of the most
critical paths for securing
your software supply chain.
It's the gatekeeper by which
code changes are released out
to your users and has many entry
points for vulnerabilities,
pulling resources
from a large number
of internal and external sources
while accepting contributions
from hundreds or maybe even
thousands of developers
and other contributors
at your company.
In the SolarWinds breach, that,
in part, led to the White House
executive order, it was actually
a compromise built system
that attackers used to inject
malware into the candidate
release that was ultimately
published to downstream users.
So in this talk, we're
going to focus in
on the build process
specifically and talk
about how to improve the
security posture of your built
environment.
And we're going to do this by
focusing on three main areas.
One, network security.
Two, build permissions.
And three, binary authorization.
So let's start with
network security.
One of the risks
to an organization
is data exfiltration
at build time.
Built by their nature
typically handle
a large amount of private
intellectual property
across source code, databases
and artifact repositories.
Now, actually, we
want to minimize
the risk of any of this data
egress to the public internet,
whether it happens to be
maliciously or just simply
accidentally.
The most common way
that companies do this
is by hosting resources
inside their private network
behind a firewall.
Traditionally,
this has meant then
that you are self hosting
your own CI/CD solution.
And besides just the additional
overhead and total cost
of ownership around
developer velocity of having
to install, manage, upgrade
and scale this system,
it also means that you're
responsible for securing it.
And as we saw with
the SolarWinds attack,
bad actors can try to corrupt or
attack the build system itself.
In the case of SolarWinds,
where at build time,
when a file was fetched
from the source repo,
it was actually swapped
out with malicious code
and then sent to downstream
users through the compile,
build and publish process.
So let's take a
different approach.
Fully managed solutions,
like Google's Cloud Build,
offer a different tactic
and are hosted and managed
by Google Cloud running in
Google's secure network,
taking the burden off
of you and your team
for having to secure the system
itself in terms of accessing
the workers that builds run on.
In June, Cloud Build launched
Private Pools, a new feature
which lets you securely
connect a fully managed
build system into your private
network using VPC network
peering.
It supports private IPs on the
worker, data regionalization
and static IP ranges
for IP allow listing.
Another common pattern
with this firewall approach
alone is that, in
many organizations,
it's treated as all or nothing.
There's inside the firewall
and outside the firewall.
Then once inside, you can
access anything that is also
inside the private network.
Now, one of the best practices
that we want to follow
is that builds can
access only what
they need to and nothing more.
So let's say, for
example, that you
have resources in
multiple GCP projects
that your build needs to access.
How could we
configure Cloud Builds
so that it can access
these resources, but only
these resources and
nothing else that would
be sort of an attack factor?
So this is where VPC
Service Controls come in.
With Private Pool support
for VPC Service Controls,
you can configure
Cloud Build to restrict
access more granularly
to just the services
that it needs to access.
Additionally, you can use VPC
Service Controls on the project
that the worker pool itself
is in to restrict egress
and an additional
layer of security
against leakage of data
to the public internet.
Using Private Pool's support
for the GCP org policy,
you can enforce
that all builds are
run on these approved worker
pools that were successfully
set up by your security team.
So now we talked about
network security,
let's move over to
build permissions
where we have two main goals.
Again, we want to grant builds
only the permissions they need
and nothing more.
And second, we want to avoid
the escalation of permissions
from the build
system to developers.
We don't want developers to be
able to access our production
environments directly or decrypt
production secrets that the
build system needs but
developers shouldn't really
have direct access to.
So as an example, let's say we
have two environments, staging
and production.
The first thing
we're going to do
is enforce that all changes
go through our source
repo, or version control
system, which then invokes
the build automatically.
This has a number of benefits,
including change history,
audit trail, CI tests.
And using productive
branches, we
can enforce that only developers
that have commit rights
to the prod branch
have the ability
to invoke the production
release pipeline.
This lets us use pull
requests to add a approval
or manual review layer
to all suggested changes
from developers that don't have
permission to release directly
to production.
Likewise, we're going
to want to make sure
that the staging build doesn't
have permissions to access
our production environment
either, which would allow
another escalation
of permissions
to environments and
secrets that should not
be accessible from
our staging pipeline.
For that, we're going
to take advantage
of a new feature of Cloud
Build for user-provided service
accounts.
In this instance, we're
going to create two service
accounts, one for
our staging bill
and one for our production
bill, and grant them
the respective permissions that
they need so that they can only
access the resources
that are needed
in each of those environments.
Next, we're going to use
Cloud Build's integration
with Secret Manager for
managing the secrets.
With Cloud Build's native
Secret Manager integration,
secrets are only
decrypted at build time,
and so not available in plain
text in the build config
or to developers.
And because you're
using Secret Manager,
it's much easier and faster
to rotate secrets frequently
further, improving
your security posture.
The last thing we're going to
do is add a manual approval step
for the production pipeline.
Using Cloud Build's
approval features,
we are going to make
sure that an admin
or other approved reviewer
is able to manually
review and approve all
production deployments.
And all of this is
in the spirit of,
again, preventing access
from individual developers
to production environments
and other secrets
that they should not be
able to access directly
while enabling the build
system to deploy to production.
So now we've talked about
build permissions as well.
Let's move on to the last topic,
which is Binary Authorization.
So we've created our
built pipeline that builds
our container and deploys it
out-- in this particular case,
Kubernetes Engine or Cloud Run--
through our continuous
delivery pipeline,
whether that could be the
newly announced Cloud Deploy,
an open source solution like
Spinnaker or even Cloud Build
itself.
But how do we enforce that only
approved builds are deployed
to our runtime environments?
What's stopping a bad
or unauthorized actor
from building their
own image and then
deploying that out
directly or injecting it
into our CD pipeline?
For this we're going to
leverage Binary Authorization
from GCP, which lets
you define deployment
policies for which containers
can and can't be deployed.
So in this case, let's
create a policy that
says only containers
built by Cloud Build
can be deployed out
to GKE or Cloud Run.
This will ensure that any
unsigned images or images
signed by an untrusted build
system will fail our policy
check and not get deployed
out to our production users,
whether trying to be deployed
directly or through our CD
pipeline.
Lastly, Cloud Build will create
and assign an asset station
for each image that
it builds saying
that it was built
by Cloud Build,
allowing it to pass the binary
authorization and verification
process and get deployed
out to our environment.
So we talked quickly
about Cloud Build
and how you can use Cloud
Build to improve your security
posture to create a more
secure build environment while,
at the same time, improving
developer productivity
and reducing operational
overhead altogether.
So we talked about some of
the features that were newly
launched in 2021,
including Private Pools,
user-provided service accounts,
Secret Manager integration,
manual approvals
and better support
for Binary Authorization.
Now, let's hand
it off to Anthony
for a demo of some
of what we discussed.
Anthony.
ANTHONY BUSHONG:
Thanks, Christopher.
Let's dive into how we can put
these principles into practice.
Let's start by taking a look
at our Cloud Run application.
In this case, we're utilizing a
containerised Python Flask web
app that's accessible
at this URL.
And it's only accessible
by authorized users,
so it will provide a token
when issuing a request.
And you'll see that we get
a HTML page in response
to our request.
Our Cloud Run
application actually
has Binary
Authorization enabled.
As a reminder,
Binary Authorization
is the ability to only admit a
certain set of container images
to your runtime environment,
like Cloud Run or GKE.
In this case, we've configured
Binary Authorization
to only approve images that have
been signed by the Cloud Run
attestor.
In this case, the
Cloud Run attestor
is only signing
images that have been
built with Google Cloud Build.
We can see Binary
Authorization in action
if we try to deploy an image
to the Cloud Run service that
was not signed by our tester.
So in this case, for
our next 2021 app,
you'll see here that I have
a container image that's
tagged rogue, and this
was built out of band,
not utilizing
Google Cloud Build.
And if I was to try to deploy
this container image to Cloud
Run, we should actually see
our Binary Authorization policy
in action by denying
that container image
to be deployed to Cloud Run.
Now that we've demonstrated
how we can handle images
that we don't trust,
let's take a look
at the automation that
Cloud Build provides
and how we can build
images that we do trust.
To build our container image,
what we're actually utilizing
are Google Cloud Build's
support for triggers.
Both of these
triggers are connected
to my GitHub repository titled
Next 2021, which actually
has our application code.
The first trigger kicks
off builds automatically
based on any changes
to a feature branch.
In this case, it'll run builds
that build a container image,
signs a container image,
and will actually open up
a pull request against the
main branch in the GitHub
repository.
The second trigger
actually kicks off
and deploys the container
image to Cloud Run
based on any changes
made to the main branch.
One of the things we
want to consider here
is the ability to apply the
principle of least privilege.
And in this case, we're
actually able to do this
by separating the service
accounts that each of these
triggers utilize.
You can see here, for
the first trigger,
we're utilizing
a service account
that is titled build-next-2021.
And this has permissions
to the Container Registry
and things like
that that actually
help it to perform the
build that it needs to run.
And then the second
service account
is called deploy-next-2021,
which has permissions
to deploy to Cloud Run.
While in this example I'm
utilizing a GitHub.com
repository, it is
important to call out
that Google Cloud Build also has
support for self-hosted source
code management systems
like GitHub Enterprise.
So you can actually see
here that in Cloud Build
I actually have a host
connection to a private GitHub
Enterprise server that I
also utilize in Google Cloud.
And you can see that I've
actually made connections
to various repositories in that
GitHub Enterprise instance.
This means that
I can also create
Cloud Build triggers on
these private self-hosted
repositories.
Now let's take a
look at the actual
build that our first
trigger is running.
This trigger is looking
in the build folder.
And the first
trigger specifically
is looking at the build.yaml
specification for Google Cloud
Build.
Our first build step is building
our container image that
will end up running
in Cloud Run,
and we're actually
publishing that
to Google Container Registry.
And you can see here that
we're utilizing Cloud Native
Buildpacks to automatically
generate that container image.
Once we've signed
the container image,
our final build step actually
will open up a pull request
against our GitHub repository.
And you can see here that the
way that we're able to do this
is that we're utilizing
the GitHub API.
And in order to
authorize ourselves,
or the build, to be able
to perform this action,
we're providing a GitHub token.
And so one of the critical
components of a secure
build environment is
careful secret management.
In this case, Google
Cloud Build allows
us to natively access secrets
stored in Google Cloud Secret
Manager.
So you can see in this
scenario we're actually
storing our token, our GitHub
token, in Secret Manager
and providing that back to the
build itself as an environment
variable.
This means that we are not
providing static credentials
to our actual build
or codifying that
into our build of
container images,
but rather these are
dynamically accessed
utilizing the service account,
which is provided to the build.
If we jump over to Google
Cloud's Secret Manager,
we'll see our secret,
our GitHub token.
And we'll see here
under permissions
that we've actually granted
secret access or permissions
to our build-next-2021 service
account, which is being
utilized by Google Cloud Build.
And the important thing
to note is that this
is a granular permission.
It is not for all secrets that
are stored in Secret Manager,
but rather on a per
secret access basis.
The next important field
to call our attention to
in the Cloud Build specification
is under options worker pool.
This actually allows for
us to specify on a per
build basis whether or not a
build should run in a Cloud
Build private pool.
So what is a Cloud
Build private pool?
Well, private pools extend
the user configurability
for the workers that
actually run a user's build.
So in this case, we can specify
additional things like regions.
We can also specify and have
access to more machine types.
And perhaps, most
importantly, we
have private VPC connectivity
to access private resources,
either within our own
network in Google Cloud
or within the data center that
is connected to our Google
Cloud VPC.
So you can see here
that I have specified
for sandbox-private pool
to have connectivity
to sandbox-VPC-privatepools,
which is actually running
in the GitHub Enterprise server
that I was showing earlier
in this demonstration.
Not only do we get
private VPC connectivity
with Cloud Build private
pools, we actually
have the ability to remove
external IPs from our workers
altogether.
And in general, can
now consider how
we can use VPC Service Controls
to secure our build perimeter
running in private pools.
So now let's actually
trigger this first
build that'll run
on a private pool.
So I'm going to change
the web application
and just add a couple of
small, very minor changes
by adding a couple
of exclamation points
in some of the HTML.
And I'm going to commit this
to the development branch,
and then what we're
going to want to do
is create a feature branch that
will kick off our trigger now
that we're done with
the development branch.
And as you can see,
our build is now
queued to run in US-west1
on a private pool.
And if we actually
dig into the build,
we can see our build steps,
which builds a container image,
attests a container image,
or signs a container image,
and then creates that
GitHub pull request.
And after a short
amount of time,
we can see that our build has
completed, the final step being
the pull request being created.
So if we actually jump
over to the repository,
we can actually see the PR
from feature against main.
And so we can review that.
We can see that our
build is completed,
and now we can utilize
it as an opportunity
to basically gate the next build
because we have the opportunity
to either approve and
merge these changes
or we can close the PR.
So in this case, once
we click on merge,
we're actually going to kick
off the second trigger which
will deploy the
service to Cloud Run.
So we're going to click that.
And that branch has now
been successfully merged.
So if we quickly glance at the
build that is going to run,
we can see here that
it's a single step,
and we're just using G
Cloud as our build step,
and we are passing
in the arguments
to basically deploy to
Cloud Run, our latest image
that we built. Now let's
take a look at our last
build from the
second trigger that
will deploy our new container
image to Google Cloud Run.
One of the things to consider
is that many teams will often
introduce a manual approval
stage for pipelines
that deploy to a
production environment,
and this basically allows
for an operator or developer
to have that final decision
to actually promote an image
into a production environment.
So as you can see,
Google Cloud Build
has actually introduced the
notion of manual approvals.
So we can see that the
trigger has created our build.
However, the build has
not begun to execute
to actually deploy to Cloud
Run because I have not yet
approved it.
So once we click off Approve,
we may have the ability
to provide context
on perhaps monitoring
or certain documentation or a
ticket that actually captures
whatever metrics or
heuristics that allow
us to promote this production.
And we can click
Approve, and our
build will actually begin
to kick off and run.
And after a short
period of time,
we'll see that our single
step build has completed
and we have now deployed the new
container image to Cloud Run.
So let's take a
look at Cloud Run.
And we can actually see
that we have a new revision.
This was the failed
revision that
was not signed by the attester
in Google Cloud Build,
so it failed to deploy due
to Binary Authorization.
But because we built this
image with Cloud Build
and it was actually properly
signed by the Cloud Run
attester that we had, it is
now successfully deployed.
And once we issue that request
again to our application,
we can see our changes with the
additional exclamation points.
We demonstrated
how we can secure
our build environments
with granular
build permissions,
a secure network
perimeter, manual approvals
and admission control
to targets like
Cloud Run and GKE.
Back to you, Christopher.
CHRISTOPHER SANSON:
Thanks, Anthony.
That was a great demo.
Now, of course, what we just
covered today was really
meant as an introduction and
a high level overview of some
of the specific
actions you can take
to secure part of your
larger end-to-end ecosystem.
If you're interested
in learning more,
here are some
additional talks here
at Next around securing
your software supply
chain that we highly recommend
you check out as well.
Thank you for your time.
And we're happy to
take any questions.